My stomach is lighter in the morning, but I haven't noticed a pattern with fatty foods. I was taking digestive from, from decide for health, but didn't seem to help.
Okay, so digestive is our clear digestive.
So digestive, so I can't remember if I made a video about this.
But I think it's, I think it's in the blog post. It's really, really important. I never make a video about it because the proper way to dose.
I had a cork acid in digestive enzymes is really too looking for the blog here is really to take. Okay, so let's say a person has bloating issues and we're going to start at the top. That's what you do when you're dealing with digestion.
Okay, so let's start at the top and you, um, um, uh, uh, everything, uh, let's see if each one of the top is, well, there's your looking at them.
You, you know, are able to produce saliva to be able to produce talent that's going to help break down carbohydrates and you know, before they get to your stomach, whether you're chewing your food, you have to chew your food and order to you to some crete.
Hydro cork acid, that's why I'm not a big fan of chewing gum a lot, because when you chew gum, you're stimulating hydro cork acid production, when you don't have food coming down there.
So it gets to your stomach, you need to produce it up hydro cork acid. Here's the blog post.
Let me change my share screen here.
And, uh, you can see it.
And it's H, you go back to Pylori, information and care talks about H Pylori, what H Pylori does.
And the importance of HCL stage one, we move a dietary antigens testing for antigen and stuff, but starting at the top for digestion really is starting with a digestive enzymes so that you have HCL
in your, in your stomach, when you have food, and I like it that just depends on that is also going to have digest the product that's also have digestive enzymes.
But you have to dose that HCL up to the point that it's going to work. So you could say well, I started taking one and it really didn't help.
You got to dose it up. I've had people that have to take seven eight nine HC nine of the clear digest or a similar product.
Per meal for a week or two before the bloating started going down and then you start titrating down so you titrate up and then you titrate down.
Some people there, their stomach is in such bad shape, maybe possibly ulcers that they can't even take HCL.
They have to, let's say they take clear digest and oh my gosh, it gave me a stomachache when I took that clear digest or any HCL product in.
Well, then in this article it says then you have to go do the apple cider vinegar test.
Take two titles, builds of apple cider vinegar. So put the HCL clear digest product away for a little bit and you just use apple cider vinegar.
If that causes burning as well, then we got to take another step backwards and you got to heal the gut with products like clear GI.
If you don't have cancer, which has got a lot of different herbs in it to help heal the gut lighting, but it doesn't have some glutamated.
So you have to be careful of using that when you have cancer, where you could just go with just some of those individual products that are in there like deglycerated licorice and and remember all the ingredients that are in that and start healing the gut lighting.
This would be a person, if they have burning, they definitely have a bolster. So they have to heal that first and then we go back to this step and we start giving the product with HCL and digestive enzymes.
And then you dose it up, you've titrated up to well by bloody it's all gone. And now you start titrated down, you don't need to stay on four or five six seven of these per wheel for the rest of your life, you titrate down.
So then you know, eventually you don't necessarily take any that's the goal, you know, your stomach is producing it up HCL.
And I think I did make a video, a number of years back, the importance of HCL everybody's talking about alkalizing their cancer. Well, one of the reasons why your tissue.
The tissues have an imbalance of acidity is because you're not making enough HCL in your stomach.
How's that actually doing with my love or my liver? Well, has everything to do it because the production of HCL by your final glands of your stomach actually gives off a base that goes into your blood and alkalizes your tissues.
Everybody works. So when you eat food and your stomach is healthy and you produce HCL and your stomach makes more HCL, then you actually alkalize your tissue.
Well, one of the issues when I'm not making a lot of HCL because I have, you know, not treated my stomach well, I've eaten a bunch of crap that it's damaged my stomach lining, so I don't make HCL very well.
And then I end up with Hpylori, which decreases HCL production even more so, then I'm not creating an alkaline substances that are going to alkalize my tissue, so not creating my carbonates that are alkalizing my tissue.
So then it's a negative cycle now Hpylori, which is a gram positive bacteria is created in over abundance in my stomach, it gets worse that could actually create a gastric cancer.
This is the cause solely of gastric and doando ulcers. This is one of the top five causes of cardiovascular disease and it will deal you a dysfunction.
Very, very important to deal with the gut, you know, not one that says you heal the gut, you heal everything, but if you don't address the gut, you know, you are doing that at your own risk.
Because it just causes ulcerative problems. So this is a good blog post, I have to actually create some videos to go on this blog post too.
Oh, I did, I created a couple, but these, these ones are all new, but look at this, I'll actually create some videos that will help with that too.